John captures the imagination of the
audiences and dominates almost every
single scene he's in he's a special
person Jon Voight you are an amazing
artist and a beloved icon of the
American film
congratulations receiving the National
Medal of Arts is a tremendous tremendous
achievement and you deserve it actor Jon
Voight of course did receive the
National Medal of Arts from President
Trump last week and now days later the
Hollywood a-lister sits down with her
own Raymond Arroyo to discuss what
receiving the distinguished award means
to him his support for Trump and his
thoughts on the impeachment fight what
did you think of that moment I mean this
is the highest medal and award that the
United States government bestows it to
an artist yeah isn't that wonderful I
mean there's so many deserving people
out there to have been to have a slate
of pictures that deserve some attention
and that growth is quite you know very
humbled by the whole thing you know and
but this look at the grace with which he
presented my name you know it was
wonderful to be to be with Allison and
Mary and the other you know awardees and
to have that wonderful host you know
he's a wonderful host and makes you feel
included and takes care of everybody you
know people in that kind of situation
you don't know am i standing in the
right place then I have to turn I have
to do this and also he makes everybody
comfortable and there was a moment where
it felt like a living room John when the
the music from Midnight Cowboy played
and this happened what would happened
here why did you jump up like this
what happened there you were inspired
you were going with it I thought Dancing
with the Stars was auditioning oh yeah
you were going you know I was doing it
because he's playful yes yes so I was
warned that you know you never can tell
what he'll do John so just go go with it
whatever was and when he started playing
the music and I don't know how many
people identified that music as the
midnight music but when it played and it
played for some length before I got up
you know I said well I better do
something because here's the music
somebody should come up so I got up I
didn't know quite what I was gonna do
you know and then I I did this kind of
you know I just tipped it a little bit
by doing a little playful something you
know voguing the character of Joe Buck
we're going to talk about late and then
I sat down and I did you know embrace it
and certainly it showed that don't take
myself that seriously when you see a
Bobby DeNiro coming out and telling the
president to go like himself or Madonna
saying she has fantasies and blowing up
the White House you think what well I
think you know when I was back in the
sixties I was I was not that extreme but
I was attended toward that that thought
you know that that kind of thinking of
the period was it's nice to be a
revolutionary you know iconoclastic when
you're a young person you think you're
doing something brand-new and all of
this stuff and you don't know you don't
look at the the real result of all of
this
the a youthful energies right arrogance
arrogance right but I've been there so
when I hear them those two you mentioned
and others I know you know this lifetime
perhaps they'll come to an understanding
that that's wrong what do you make of
this impeachment inquiry well it's a lie
as I have said and this it's it's the
culmination of the commitment to take
down this president you said this battle
is a war but as a performer no how is
the audience receiving this yeah I well
I think you know what I think I think
it's a way of exposing the truth it's
here we have these people in bad
behavior I'll say you know look at the
statements of Nancy Pelosi I look at
this fellowship Adam Schiff I say it's
pretty clear there's something wrong
here these people are not well and and
the audience is seeing the bottom line
just as they're seeing the bottom line
with these debates one ridiculous
statement after another that's what the
Democratic Party is and they're getting
a view of it